[Music]
in comedian drama news what yeah Jamaica
me hungry a comedy club owner slams Pete
Davidson for ditching his set at the
last minute you ain't even here I did
Pete Davidson gets slammed no cuz he
ditched his set I have a set of
backwards yeah you did real quick pulled
it out of my ass because I was like what
are these words floating around in here
is Pete Davidson the albino sno right
yeah yeah well you know the Arianna the
one that looks like a Tweaker okay
Arianna he's not albino well he has
colored hair oh [ __ ] I'm trippin no oh
no no I saw a picture what it was all
like blonde hair but he's no blonde is
still not white it was like white
platinum yeah talking about this photo
and it's still but his I don't know it
was like albino like David just say you
made a mess
look that photo up tell me I'm wrong his
eyes are dark though that's why I
thought he's a Tweaker yeah you like no
you can't have dark I know it's like
really light light light light blue eyes
you guys like pink sister okay
I'm trippin in what so he ditched his
set at a comedy club so this is a club
owner and I'll tall is Pete Davis is my
god yeah or the club owners Hey okay so
they're reporting and now he's going to
war with this comedy club owner because
the owner said that so he went up on
stage
and he did this five-minute set when
after he asked Pete Davidson hey can I
open for you Pete Davidson was like no I
travel with my own opener guy you know
which is normal yeah the owner still
went ahead and did a five-minute set and
in that set he started very
sarcastically told the crowd not to
mention Kate Beckinsale or ariana grande
Cammie only dates Phan [ __ ] yeah
because he had requested for them to not
talk about it
and so after that Pete Davidson just
immediately left because he was like
[ __ ] that I'm being disrespected oh yeah
he's ruining his ruining his set too
like you're [ __ ] ruining it from day
what are you doing exactly but the
people that were there they're pretty
much taking Vinnie Vinnie side if that
was like your only rule like don't talk
about these people how the [ __ ] would
you do it that yeah and then also say
very sarcastically so this happened in
Connecticut by the way the club is
called Vinnie brand's stress it sounds
like the club owner wants to be the
famous guy but so then he just opens for
famous people and then posted a video on
his Instagram explaining and then after
this Instagram video you're gonna see
the club owner responding to this video
Oh tired because he played this video in
his club okay Wow baby yes dude guys I'm
sorry that we had to leave the show
before I got to go on the owner of any
brand disrespected me and did something
that I told them not to do and I can't
you know perform under those
circumstances whoever everybody who got
tickets to that show I am doing a free
show for you guys where it's gonna be in
the next week and you know all get will
get it all sorted out sorry again this
is not your fault
that's really nice yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the club owner is saying that the
security security guy told him this why
would the security guy tell him to say
that yeah no you see I just pulled out
of his ass yeah it sounds like it it
doesn't make any sense yeah so he's
saying that the security guy told him
not to mention the two girls but then
that he ended up Oh
so the security guys like hey whatever
you don't mention these two girls and so
he announced on stage hey I'm not gonna
mention these two girls yeah you dumb
[ __ ] like what are you stupid
yeah is still on Vinnie side you could
hear that I'm cheering what cuz they
believe his story that the security yeah
there's only one sided and maybe you're
bummed out that they're missing the
comic they put they paid for it was like
their one night out they go with the
drink so they could to find out about
the mute like the free show mmm and then
that's why that's that crowd or is that
another night it's the theme closed that
night yeah that same night something
seems fishy to me
some don't seem right something doesn't
seem right some if the he said she said
type of deal right now I don't know we
need to get into the bottom of this or
he was just so passionate that the crowd
wanted to be on his side so it doesn't
explode so this was the same night the
Mexico border did that thing the same
night that's what they're
oh yeah that fool look like he was about
to have a stroke yeah I thought he was
gonna pass out there's comics like that
that go so hard that they have a vein
that's permanently like popping out
there so hacky the ones that are like
that cuz I think because her jokes
aren't hitting hard enough they have to
make the delivery extra crazy funny my
stuff this morning you guys get it
ghosts and it's hard man cuz I still
watch a lot of stand-up when I was a
teenager on Comedy Central Joe Rogan
used to be like that and then I think as
he got funny I used like you started to
realize nothing on that so even like
appel Chappelle was super gimmicky but
we loved it you know but now his new
[ __ ] his super just just chill chill and
it's way funnier yeah these guys are so
good you know old boner for comedy then
it's hard it is when you find a good
comedian like oh man this can happen
they have like us a set that you know
works and then it's not working with
that crowd and you're just like how do I
make it work and then you're just trying
it I haven't done stand-up in so long
but I started doing it to getting these
comic College shows this year and yeah
because these guys know like I don't
really prep anything I could go really
off-the-cuff you don't do for fun -
three years you can't do not the cup
yeah yeah and like the first show that I
did this year
I completely blinged out and I just went
okay it was it was pretty good you get
coffee because you remember how you used
to be able to do it yeah and I was like
oh [ __ ] it was only like 20 minutes in
because I can usually go for about 30-40
minutes easy and the toyman's in I went
blank I was like oh [ __ ] I haven't one
plate like this in years
it just says that muscle isn't but yeah
yeah but it was pretty bad hey David
blue ocean I blanked out it was like oh
this stuff is really hard huh stage me
like a stand-up siren huh bye good night
I'm David so that's why it's good to
also watch other comics not to like take
the material but just to watch somebody
do it it gets you like amped up it gets
you in the vibe of it yeah you're like
second guess a lot of your choices and
for me too like I was second-guessing my
choices but at the same time you just
have to commit I forgot that
and I was like oh are they not gonna
laugh at this it was the crowd too young
for this yeah and it doesn't matter
doesn't matter just do it that's why if
I don't personally like a comic it's
still very hard for
to be like they suck or anything cuz it
takes so much to just be on stage in the
first place [ __ ] yeah you know like they
might not and you don't know if they're
having an off night exactly sometimes
people get everyone gets nervous stage
the day my boyfriend broke up with me oh
I had to go on stage there your missus
what's-her-face oh yeah oh yes that is
true yeah and it actually produced
better material out of that cuz you're
emotional
yeah maybe mm-hmm did you drink no I
don't have been exactly like yeah that's
true show your tits I did not not that
night now some comics are just really
really bad though you just go on yeah
it's like while you are not made for
this yeah there's some really really bad
cop there's some really bad ones on
Netflix and I'm like how did you get
this they get their hour special yes you
oh you go this way thumb down oh no what
Steve gives her that I can't give you
those grip options that Steve can I give
you this way I do both hands did I go
over and under she was both were [ __ ]
all forearms here she just [ __ ] puts
it in the middle she usually just a
[ __ ] wrap it around both arms and do
one of these
yeah but Stan accompanies really hard
and dies I think I've become less
critical over the years of content
creators in the very beginning I think I
was way more critical Sam and then the
more you understand and know and the
difficulties behind everything it's it's
the opposite that happened to me
everybody just has like their different
flavors what we start that's what it is
yeah I think as mother the the more you
grow your palate gets bigger and you
start to understand because in the very
elementary stages you're kind of like a
snob yeah because you're also insecure
so your world is really [ __ ] small
and you think you got the special like
knowledge that no one else has
but everyone know how to do it this is
how we do it that you're doing it wrong
this is the way you do yeah and then
later you're like oh we all have
different types and vibes or different
audiences you're going for different
things yeah first thing who is that art
made for
that's like you know like a lot of
people a lot of young boy teens don't
like like you know heartthrob music it's
like it's not made for you dude
it's also hard to say like because we
kind of see it as there's I mean there's
never gonna be a thousand Dave
Chappelle's you know so you're like oh
this person's not like Bill burr or Dave
Chappelle but how many of those are
there right so there's a lot of like
yeah who are funny but they they
probably won't in the stand-up comic
world anyways like there's people like
yeah you're kind of funny like I think I
mean I'm the kind of funny world but
I'll never reach this level you know so
I also have to know where I'm at but
there's people who just like this - not
everybody even Kevin Hart's team the
ones that's been rolling with him for
like the past 15 20 years they know
they'll never be as funny as him but
they still help right for him because
they know that that's the magic that
makes it work so they're not gonna [ __ ]
with the system we're gonna continue to
open for them for the next 10 years and
we'll keep writing material for him but
we're just never gonna get that
superstar status that Kevin archive
that's so sad but kind of true though
yeah it's very good for them
it is Kevin Hart was like hey I want you
to write me this [ __ ] do it i
lobbyist and a comic all right for you
you know I think it's like it's not just
husband huh no that was lol though it's
because it's not just being funny or
like having a skill or being able to do
the craft well it's also this
personality like this belief in yourself
I think it takes to become a star star
you got to be a complete narcissist yes
oh yeah and not everyone can do the
illusional narcissist like if you have
the the Indian securities of those
doubts and stuff it's not you're not
mental yes there's much a lot of
charisma yeah but the charisma also
comes from believing in yourself and
believing they're trying a lot there's a
lot of people on YouTube I think are hot
trash this is my opinion doesn't mean
that their stuff isn't good to somebody
though
[Music]